Anthony I'm gonna start with you it's
not a shock that oratory command of
language rhetorical skills are not
something that is prominent in the
current White House that said you are
very interested in language in the way
in which language is used the way
language can be misused in the way can
you be used to persuade people did you
start from the idea of looking at what
Winston Churchill said in this period of
time before you started analyzing where
those words were going to get him in I
think so yes I think every writers you
know interested in the proposition that
words count matter and can make a
difference
I started way back ten years ago in fact
I became aware that three of the
greatest speeches of all time were
written and delivered by mr. Winston
Spencer Churchill all within be
incredibly implausible period of four
weeks to for a political leader to have
one of those speeches would be
extraordinary to have written three
asked a question why how where did he
write these speeches what were the
forces that compelled him and I did a
bit more research and it was nothing
less than the collapse of Western and
Central Europe and massive domestic
pressure to do a peace deal with that of
Hitler just run that but that last
phrase back again do a peace deal with
that over Hitler Winston Churchill do a
peace deal who knew I certainly didn't
know and I saw I had this idea that's a
movie but I didn't really have the the
gumption or the hubris or the the
confidence to do it so I sort of didn't
didn't really tackle it until after I'd
done theory of everything had such a
happy experience with that film that I
thought I'll give it a go and if nothing
happens if I mess it up I won't tell
anyone and anyway that's what I did and
I finished the script and then I thought
hmm now I need some geniuses to come and
join me in this
and I was richly served by some of the
gentlemen you see before you and Joe I
suspect you were one of those first
people in Atonement you'd already
visited Dunkirk did you feel that there
was a part of history that you didn't
know that you felt was worth sharing
that told the story that wasn't on the
beach very much so I mean I I as you say
he had looked at this exact period of
time from a very different angle and to
read Antony's screenplay and understand
the the kind of backstory of that moment
in history and to to really be very
surprised by it and and I felt that it
was a story that I was very excited to
share Gary I suspect when a call comes
in about Winston Churchill there's two
pull or opposite reactions bloody hell
what are you thinking and bloody hell
yes is your reaction a little bit of
both that this is a great opportunity
but also a terrifying opportunity
exactly yes well obviously I had I could
I knew why Joe wanted me to cast me
because I have an a striking resemblance
to Winston Churchill man yeah you think
what a crazy idea
then you think this is like being asked
to play for staff or King Lear or
something you know it's a wonderful
opportunity so it's a mix of excitement
and and and and fear also you're
following in the footsteps of many many
great people that are played in before
so it's it's not like it was a it was
particularly in the last couple of years
it's a pretty crowded field
how much reference is too much reference
and how much does the reference kind of
belie the way in which we think Winston
Churchill behaved spoke and looked well
you I mean I you know you sort of close
your eyes and you try and think of
winter you know you think okay Winston
Churchill and then you're not sure if
you're really if if you're contaminated
by those actors so you am I thinking of
Winston or am I thinking of Albert
Finney or Robert Hardy or so you have to
sort of move that to one side to begin
with you do you know the reading which
is sort of you might say required
required reading but what was
fascinating in a revelation to me was
going to the newsreel footage and seeing
someone who was who was energized and
had full of vitality was was was was was
dynamic and he has been Winston has been
in the past he's been represented in
later in life in infirmity or an older
Winston and you have this image of this
sort of chromosome with his cigar and
whiskey sort of shuffling around in
carpet slippers and this this Winston in
is certainly in 1940 was was a dynamic
force to be reckoned with then we know
that the King had a speech impediment we
really don't know a lot or at least
American audiences don't know a lot
about what kind of person he was how
much history is there about him and did
you find a path in through reference
that you found useful um yeah there's a
lot known about him I mean you know he's
a the royal family any member of any
monarch is certainly covered from to
breakfast so the the the most important
thing was just being able to watch the
the man himself there's a lovely piece
of him at like a boy's camp doing like a
little sing-along thing and stuff like
this he was a true believer he really
believed in the old in you know in the
old line of monarchy he and he had to he
had to do that so and listening to his
speech yes he and Lionel who's Geoffrey
Rush in the
speech had been at it for a while so if
you take colin firth as a as a sort of a
starting point they'd been working
together for a couple of years by the
time you you meet him now and if you
listen to the indian use the speeches of
the time you know he's better at it than
i am but you know i try and make a stick
of it what kind of access did you have
to the locations that are in part of the
story i mean you can go visit the
churchill war rooms today i don't know
if you're able to get into 10 Downing
Street or you have to build that what
kinds of access did you get him what
does it mean to the actors to either
visit those real places or be able to
create them as authentically as your
production designer could we got into
pretty much everywhere to research
apart from Buckingham Palace but
actually my dad had been to Buckingham
Palace because he was the first person
ever to get a medal from the Queen to
serve for services to the art of British
puppetry so you might laugh but the
Queen they're okay they're a mad person
who got yeah my mum so anyway sorry
question serious serious serious I'm
sorry it's been a long month so yes we
did we got into some extraordinary
places including Downing Street and
we're the first film crew actually ever
to shoot on Downing Street Winston when
he's going in and out of 10 Downing
Street is actually going in the real
building David Cameron gave us
permission just before he got by the way
shirt resume wasn't happy but the deal
had been done I'm on the way out do what
you like so so yeah we weren't able to
shoot in the House of Commons well they
gave us permission but to shoot there
but they said no non-elected non
democratically elected bottoms were
allowed to sit on the benches which kind
of didn't make sense so we built that
and we built the war rooms although the
the hall that Winston walks through and
so on is
is that the Palace of Westminster that
the Parliament and and everything else
is locations which was which is great
III really enjoyed shooting on location
again that idea Joe and I think is this
is true for the King to the idea of
doubt of being open to different points
of view to actually see that you may not
be right in your thinking and listen to
other people that seems to be a very
important idea of the film was that
something you latched on to as a
director especially in the scenes with a
king about who is and it is not telling
the truth or the leading the right way
um yeah I had a piece of paper um little
post-it note on the on the screen as I
cut the film that just says doubt doubt
for me was the reason why I responded to
the material in the first place I'd um
he had doubts about the script no I had
doubts about myself I just I just made a
movie cool of them okay so I just made I
just made a movie called pan and it lost
a hell of a lot of money and it had been
universally slated and I doubted myself
enormous Lee and I doubted my position
in the industry I thought maybe I don't
understand audiences and I don't
understand the industry and maybe I
should retire gracefully and just make
puppet theater as your parents did as my
parents did don't laugh it was a fine
art puppetry
so um so I was going through I was going
through a process of extreme doubt and
and then this script came along and I
thought maybe this is an opportunity to
turn that doubt into something positive
and that seemed to be what the film was
about and that seemed to be what my
journey in making the film could be
about too so so that that crisis of
confidence that Churchill suffers that
at the end of the second act
the end of the fourth act is is integral
to the film I think it's about the idea
that doubt can lead to great to wisdom
is is an important component in the
attainment of wisdom and that's what I
got from apart from sheer entertainment
that's why I got from the screenplay
Gary Ben Joe Anthony thank you all for
coming out